video of a woman being rescued from an
underground wash has gotten a lot of
attention showing just how dangerous it
is to be in there during monsoon season
so not only i was so hit here on channel
lately tonight first responders actually
went back into those tunnels with
victoria saha as they walked her through
the frightening water rescue
it's hard to imagine that this
underground wash was filled with water
last week dramatic video showed us a
woman clinging onto this pillar as water
rushed around her and today we got to
hear from the first responders who
helped save her life
a rescue mission with no time to spare
she really didn't have a lot of movement
with her arms the woman was first
spotted by north las vegas police near
the wash by commerce and craig the water
moving so fast it pushed her to lucy and
alexander where she was rescued
clark county fire captain travis grove
was one of the first crews to arrive he
says despite their rescue efforts there
was a good chance this woman would have
slipped away we swung her to the side
and when were swinging to the side she
was completely underwater submerged
battalion chief ben erickson with north
las vegas fire department also rushing
to the wash she could have gone in there
and turbine water and kind of
we could have lost her forever and we
would maybe not found her until days
later as a body recovery although this
was an all hands on deck rescue if you
look closely at the video you will
notice first responders are resisting
the urge to get into the water we want
to actually be dry we want to be on dry
ground and our
major tactic is actually to throw them
throw bags and then pull the victims to
safety there's no chance once you get
stuck in this water after the rescue
north las vegas fire evaluated all the
flood channels in the area just in case
the next storm brings them another water
rescue monsoon season isn't over just
yet first responders say it's always
dangerous to hang around here because
when it storms the washes can fill up
fast reporting in north las vegas
victoria saha live local now